je m'excuse d'avancé si j'ai l'air d'un
groupe compte maintenir mon micro de ma
main simplement que le micro du canyon
est un petit peu loin de moi et surtout
et d'une qualité particulièrement
dégueulasse dont vous vous entendiez
vraiment pas si je n'utilisais pas ce
procédé plutôt révolutionnaire on suit
les options on peut changer de sens cet
argent réel voilà aujourd'hui je vais
insensiblement vous parler de ce que y'a
venir sur ma chaîne pendant les vacances
parce que oui la zone c on vient tout
juste d'être en vacances là pendant deux
semaines et pendant ces deux semaines va
y avoir le retour de quelque chose que
vous souhaiter à tout prix revenir sur
ma chaîne bon je n'en dis pas plus mais
ceux qui sont là depuis longtemps seront
ce que c'est je pense
et croyez moi pour ce retour on a prévu
des trucs vraiment amusant avec des
idées un peu plus conne les unes que les
autres
bon évidemment mais pas notre vie en
danger ce n'est pas le but from bâtard
tu veux que je meurs et ben lamb
pour les 400 mille abonnés on a aussi
prévu un projet un petit peu spécial une
vidéo bon qu'il soit un peu de ce que je
fais d'habitude qui est un peu à white a
marqué sa part moi j'espère que ça vous
plaira dans tous les cas on est pas
encore et ça sert à rien de me stresser
bêtement me disant faut que je sorte d
euros depuis tant d'années tu me sert
depuis tant d'années je t'aime sinon je
voulais aussi vous parler des jeux vous
voyez en ce moment sur ma chaîne alors
je sais pas si ça vous plaît ou pas les
jeux un petit peu indépendant comme ça
ou même cd jeux flash carrément pour
vous dire à quel point c'est pas dégeu
oméga tous trois d'être en tout cas si
vous appréciez les jeunes joueurs comme
une sphère mario comme surgiront
simulator comme iv mario comme appui oui
sous les les jeux flash comme ça au même
des jeux pas flash comme sneijder ou
quoi c'est quand même des jeux
indépendants et pourtant qui propose du
tout est vraiment sympa on s'amuse tout
mou du tube heures que soient américains
espagnols anglais et a guère antartica
océanique mais rien est bon les îles
espaces communs tels faits pour ça vous
bombardez en commentaire le nom de jeu
que vous adorez puis moi j rich etc et
donc peut-être que la prochaine de
cholet serait sur le jeu vous aurez
proposer tous et mme fleming donc
allez-y je vous laisse me donner le nom
du jeu pas très connus gérer jeter un
coup d'oeil à tout ça d'ailleurs en
parlant iv mario qui l'avait déjà fait
mon chat
à de me filmer tu vas me réveillais
boitard willis robinet ou les chiens de
squeeze ah non je sais retire pas du
tout là y'a vraiment des filles qui
arrivent à trouver n'importe quel objet
de la vie quotidienne mignon c'est un
truc de ouf
qu'est ce que c'est que ça fait mon
affaire un constat plus que d'un mâle en
chaleur aa aussi je vais répondre à une
question qu'on me demande souvent
comment est ce que je fais pour gérer
entre les vidéos et les études parce que
oui je suis en terminale es ça me casse
les couilles al baqara vite et bien
écoutez j'ai lu pour tout de suite je ne
gère pas tout simplement
non plus sérieusement je suis pas
vraiment un grand bosseur à la base
c'est vrai qu' on ne dirait pas mais
faire la vidéo en fait c'est surtout le
montage qui prend du temps surtout pour
les best-of com/fr mario ou iv mario
mais bon voilà j'essaie quand même
trouver du temps pour faire ça faut dire
que bon je bosse pas vraiment souvent
même pas trop je sais pas si jamais été
très motivés par l'école je vous avoue
maintenant voilà faut prendre conscience
que c'est un truc vraiment important
qu'il faut qu on se démerde pour avoir
nos diplômes que vous soyez en bac pro
ans et a fait un bep en bac général ou
quoi faut vraiment moins avoir son
diplôme pour essayer de s'en sortir un
minimum dans la vie parce que oui dans
notre société moderne si je suis là-bas
ton bac sur l'échelle la graduée des du
taf tu es là et si tu la material girl a
en gros faut juste bien faire la part
des choses entre le travail scolaire le
temps libre les jeux etc et surtout le
sommeil parce que torts mire c'est la
vie
d'ailleurs je souhaite de bonnes
révisions à ceux qui sont en terminale
que moi et qui passent leur bac à la fin
de l'année bonne chance à vous bref
parenthèse scolaires fermés on est en
vacances dans la mer waouh c'est quoi
cette fin le travail car pourquoi tu
perds la toile montrant le vide du tout
le cas bref à part ça ce soir je veux
voir mon film préféré à savoir iron man
3 alors soit vraiment très grand fan
d'iron man 1 et 2 bons même si l'un est
quand même bien plus sympathique que le
jeu ait l'impression que j'ai eue c'est
que ce soit et rodman 3 est aussi
violent que cette scène
vous voulez faire du clic et du buzz sur
youtube vous savez ce qui vous reste à
faire vous prendre des panneaux de
circulation pourquoi il a fait ça bordel
c'est comme si moi je vous un truc comme
ça il ya de monde
bon à part ça parlons météo parlons
janot sur le sud-ouest de la france y
fera un temps équivalent à la
stratosphère en europe centrale
d'ailleurs en parlant du temps il ya un
truc qui me choque chaque année bordel
de merde alors c'est très simple les
gens quand il pleut ils disent à un
samui
oui fait froid ils disent [ __ ] kyle
vivement l'été les écoliers du soleil
ils disent pourquoi cette chaleur c'est
insupportable j'aime le plus c'est super
ça vous les cheveux trop quoi faire et
j'aime le froid parce que l'on peut se
couvrir on peut faire quelque chose
contre le froid et du coup après on a pu
croire mais on a chaud à cette chaleur
et si je m'achetais un ventilateur
ronnie pied comme ça j'aurais moins
chaud et je pourrai profiter pleinement
du soleil
enfin bon voilà c'est tout pour cette
première d'un petit mot montcourt avait
que squeeze on se retrouve bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo encore merci à tous
d'être nombreux à me suivre vous êtes
vraiment géniaux dites moi un
commentaire si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de lâcher vos noms de jeux
indépendants et on se retrouve bientôt
dans une nouvelle vidéo tu as tout bon
tu puisses non mais sérieux c'est mario
ou le jeu impossible à faire un bide run
a coutume de dire qu'un développeur
fourbe de merde qui est nommé des pièges
et inexistant à peu aux quatre coins de
la marque
tu es là tu vois là je vois la c3 et
quatre maillots diomède